today we presented our proposals for
a new industrial strategy for
europe the first
thing to do is innovation europe's
industry accounts for half of
exports and for these research and
development investments and it is therefore
clear that we will have
a major focus on this in the years to come
artificial intelligence is because there is qi
and all countries were very much in
agreement that we have to press ahead here
that we have to rule out
that the usa and above all asia china are moving
at high speed
the completion of the digital single market
that is a component
and  so i'm pleased that we accepted the
ordinance on the single digital
gateway today